but let's get to it and today i have one
of the greats
he's the most capped nine in history for
the all blacks
he's played over 150 games for the
highlanders
and he's had a real journey and i'm
really looking forward to getting into
this one
it is the man himself aaron smith
welcome nuggie thanks for coming on bro
cheers bro wilson will be here and uh
can't wait
how's isolation been yeah we're on day
five um last couple days has been pretty
tough but
um yeah man that is what it is the
hardest part is just uh
i think when you're away rugby you're
busy and you're kind of locked into
something
yeah but uh at the moment when i call
home all i want to do is be there and
it's been pretty tough but um trying to
fill my times with things like this
connect with people
and uh you know just do what i can
yeah i've been training pretty hard i've
got a big tv behind me i play a lot of
playstation uh
when i'm not doing much and uh yeah but
um mrs got me on a few jobs planning for
our wedding in january so
oh organizing uh suits and
alcohol and catering uh it's interesting
so
trying to keep myself busy but yeah it
is
it is tough mate so all the boys in
isolation with you at the moment
how's that work yeah we're all in one
hotel
and um it's pretty serious so we got
here
we're in our own bubble we tested
negative every week in australia
like pretty casual you know like
following rules signing in places
and then we get here it's like keep two
meters masks on
um don't go near each other our lobby is
quite thin so like they'll like
stay apart it was real serious when we
got here this guy in the air force
things like stay apart keep the distance
oh man uh i got in trouble the first
second day i um our nutritionist got on
the lift with me
and when we got to the ground floor they
had a guy waiting there like used to
have broken covered rules
sharing a lift and oh yeah that's a
warning and i was like god so
and it was our nutritious fault when i
said she jumped in with me i couldn't
really stop him
so yeah we've had a few messages from my
manager like just
follow the rules boys um but it's been
great
food's awesome coffee's good
so there's not much the food is awesome
and uh you can order water and
coke zero as an lmp at any time sort of
one with every meal and
um yes we've got a pretty good view our
hotel's mean
so um we can't really complain mate so
um it's just the time bro you just the
days drag
it's crazy yeah i bet and what's camp
being like obviously
um this season was successful you won
everything that you could have
but um with new zealand fans and new
zealand media no one's ever happy and it
probably wasn't the
year that the all blacks are expected of
so how is the camp and what's it been
like
it's been a good good year man a lot of
new guys and
we've got a new coaching group as well
so it's been really
really fun to be honest yeah um real
challenging
it was like a india tourist world cup
going to australia um yeah
i think it's just that looking back at
it and there we just have moments and
games where if we're now that
we do change perception of how good we
were or perceived but
um hopefully the odds aussies and rg's
don't score
70 odd points to steal the try nations
yeah
uh i'll be watching that game pretty
closely but um
you know for us on and off the field i
think we've grown a lot this year and i
i swear
and and i hope that people believe that
we can only get better from this too so
that's a scary proposition and i have
full faith that
our leadership group learned a lot and
the young players
we introduced from what we were said
enjoyed the environment and we tried to
make them feel
as welcome as possible and feel like
they had a voice and could add to the
environment
but um yeah we just you know we played
some quality sides
you know aussie and rg were up for games
and really happy we won the bled bled
means so much to us and
um after a little bit of a shaky start
in wellies
um we uh played two awesome games and
um show before about so yeah um
yeah it's it is what it is mate but as
you said we all expect all blacks to go
really well and uh
yeah it probably wasn't up to par with
our standard to be honest
yeah exciting times in the future those
by the sounds of that got the
environment
humming and got a lot of young boys
blooded this year right so it's a
young mate they are young they are young
calum grayson that was you
oh i didn't make the all blacks when i
was 20 though that's like different
like they're a young man and it's just
like i stayed with calum grace in there
and he was just like piling back this
food
and i was in the morning i was like how
he would you was like nah i was like i
was like hey
how does that work like he ate every rub
in sight we went to this rib joint
he ate every ribbon chicken wing he
could get and extras and i was like
cracking up like i could eat it
still light just burns it off
oh that's good stuff but anyway let's go
back to the start for you
obviously um one thing i enjoy is
hearing about how people grow up and
i know you've got an interesting journey
grew up in fielding small town
to farmer town but um yeah mate great
upbringing had everything we needed
a river a rugby field and uh bmx track
when i was younger so i was pretty happy
and uh
you know just had a normal uh here we
are bringing backyard cricket
and rugby in touch i had a field behind
me so
used to go through the old man and um
you know i just literally followed my
dad everywhere so i was quite lucky he
was a sociable character
man played twilight cricket
social rugby and i just followed him i
was a ball boy or
uh cricketer um and just yeah loved the
changing room vibe
um he enjoyed a beer so i sort of grew
up in that culture of
not elite sport but of uh just loving
competing
playing sport for fun and obviously they
enjoyed having a beer and
you know i had to go through with my dad
so um
it was awesome so when did you take
rugby when did you start playing rugby
when did you start making it serious oh
i played uh you know rugby like everyone
from five years old and
um beer feet rugby back then so standing
on the lines crying
yeah just on frosty morning
hating life um but you know yeah i was
allergic to tackling back then god i was
uh
as hell so uh i couldn't chase down and
if i couldn't chase him down and grab
them there was no uh hidden spokes back
then but
you know i loved i loved rugby and uh i
was quick when i was younger so i played
on the wing
um scored a lot of tries on the end of
the line but you know it wasn't anything
too serious but
i was probably a lot better at cricket
during my sort of teenage years and then
uh
the old man just sort of said um
you know i can't keep taking it to
cricket and rugby training
can you kind of pick one yeah and i was
like oh yeah
and um pretty much in year 11
i tried for the first thing as a bit of
a joke i got like six minutes in the
trial
all the big big guns are off man uh
mitchell croswell and sam wallock
got like the last yeah five or six
minutes yeah
and you know what we were like
15 going on 16 and now year 11 and then
the next day on the notice board they
had like the first
day like oh yeah they named the team and
then
i walked um yeah i walked past this
halfback
who was sixth form fitters his name was
uh aaron haynes and
you know i thought he was gonna be the
halfback and he just didn't say anything
to me flunked me
sure hainesy what's it up and he's like
nothing and then i was like oh and the
boy's like
get over to the notice board and i was
like oh wow what and then
me and mitchell and sam and year 11's
making the first thing was a bit of a
big deal and
i'm bloody you know 62 kgs like oh no
i've got to play for something roughly
but you must have gone pretty good in
that five minutes
oh now i think they were just sort of
from what i gathered later on they were
seeing if um haines could play the way
they wanted and
um yeah they had a sim formed halfback
that played and then i ended up playing
first five that year
um just because i could sort of pass the
ball a long way and
check a little bit and um we just had
big lucy's mate so i was just all
runners of 10
and i'd just give it to we had chris
walker george warlock and mick roswell
so
a bit of a throwback names but yeah they
were man childs at school
and the old good old stick in your
seventh so um
chris walker was a walking uh walking
beast and then george wallace and they
were class so
i either ran one two cuts with adam
whitelock and just get going line
well i'd throw a missed path to our fast
back so i
i had a good ride that year um
i always remind cozy we beat wellington
college and fielding
for the top 16. and young cozy there
with his uh was he playing
yeah beatles
so it was a good memory and uh beating
cozy in my football was pretty cool and
i remember seeing them and i was like
everybody knew who he was and um yeah so
my uh
first of these days were awesome and i
obviously got to
play with some good players yeah and you
mentioned your past they're having a
long pass how did you get such a
good pass at that age well it was
probably more when i was the teenager my
dad had kind of said you're not going to
go very tall you need to
because i was on the wing then and i was
just sort of quick but
everyone had started growing in there
and i didn't so
um he's like should we um start passing
and then we started a past thing thing
around like the old story i
maybe said is like i've heard is the
hidden in the wheelie bin every day so
when i was about 12
i started hitting the sticker on the
wheelie bird
every day both hands though so i had to
do it and then at night
when he got home from work i'd have to
come out and do it in front of me yeah
just to more my left hand than anything
he didn't care about my right
yeah and then um it progressed to like
you know
there's a fence post that was further
away and then it was like
he'd start catching balls and then yeah
we go to the park
and i remember one summer we just when i
was about 14
going for the god playing colts
yeah we were passing a lot and just
kicking and
i was trying to be a goalkeeper then
which is a failure waste the time really
should have just stuck to box cookie
but um yeah there were days a year my
dad would have caught you know hundreds
of balls every day and um
you know it was it was a cool it was our
little thing we didn't really talk
much when it happened but yeah he didn't
really know either but he just
knew that doing a lot of it would help
but him and my mom would grade a mum was
always like
you could be whatever you want dream big
like literally
every day or everything happens for a
reason you can dream big
but my dad just caught everything and as
i sit around i'd go through their
club rugby games or touch trainings and
they're like just
arrived in there and loved it and just
wanted to be one of them guys
you know but yeah it was um i don't know
mate
i um i love pasting it's a passion i
still do it try to do it every day or
when i'm in ken
every day and do some passing and it's
just for me no better feeling than
throwing a
you know a perfect spiral and when it
comes out of my fingers uh
yeah it's weird so i'd rather put
someone away for a try off a nice pass
then
score a try it's a real weird one for me
yeah how good
and so do you think you're passing to
try and be a professional rugby player
or was it more of a
just something you like to do
it was nothing about trying to be a pro
it's just trying to
my dad just was like halfbacks have to
have the nicest past
and you're not going to make it by your
physical gifts done so you need to have
skill
and uh i can see the game well
um and and see mismatches and see holes
and stuff around
hitting people you know so i was quite
lucky so
i think playing first five in my
football really dialed that in around
like
you got a bit more room hitting guys and
manipulating space and that but i think
yeah
i remember him saying that like you're
not going to make it because of your
physical gifts
you need to be the best at skill and
your skills and
he's like you just gotta have the best
path to make it and and
and it stuck with me and i think it was
a throwaway drunk comment but
i um took it pretty serious it's like
okay well
if i'm gonna have any chance at playing
at a decent level
well i didn't make any red teams and i
was younger till i was six
uh sixth form here so um
yeah i think little moments like that
like i remember
in turbo's academy when i was 19. okay
so helen's like
nagi if you start tackling mate you'll
have a rounded game
yeah because like you've just got to
make the odd technical you don't have to
tackle
yeah but you've got to make tackles when
you need to you've got a you're a great
communicator at the right
you see the game your attack's good but
you just
yeah i didn't want to tackle so there's
key moments i remember that was one of
them like
my dad was like you need to have the
best pass to play to
any level and and then miss jason
halloween around
if you start making want to make tickles
um you'll enjoy it and i really enjoy
trying to tackle now
not like i do heap but i don't i enjoy
that i actually get a lot of confidence
on my attack when i get a tackle in
early yeah um
and yeah you're a vicious tackler
yourself
so you love it you know what i mean
they've always loved the day
i don't play rugby for that but i do
enjoy it now fair enough
and then obviously my first memory of
you was at the new zealand under-19s
camp so you'd obviously
progress to that level um to be in
the frame for the new zealand under 19's
team and
i remember you coming into that camp
bubbly friendly guy
even got me over to my your room for a
haircut
you're into all that sort of stuff so
that's what i remember about you like um
real keen real keen to learn and um yeah
how did you find that cam
yeah i think that was the it was a cool
experience
i obviously didn't make nz schools or
anything and uh
i made hurricanes in there but going to
nineteen's like
i remember signing a five grand contract
with the turbos
at 19. yeah uh i signed up for my
apprenticeship
and then i got the call to go to nine
inch trials and it was just like buzzing
but when i got there mate
like uh i think we did infants
for a testing and i remember that's when
i found out how far off i was like
i remember watching you and kirbaker do
the 400 and like racing
it was like we were like 50 meters
behind and i thought holy and then
10 minutes later we'd do the 1.5 and
that was like
watching the olympics you and crap run
it so it was uh
and i was way off my i remember i was at
the 19's trials we did the 3k
i think maybe and benafiyaki was like
just behind me so i knew
then i was uh i played all right but
again that was kind of the year i said i
didn't want to tackle
and uh still didn't want to take away
that point and
i wasn't fit mate i was 70 old kgs
skinnies went there great um and then we
had that ranking board
remember they were just so ruthless they
just had like rankings and everything
speed bench squat
like they had everything tickling like
and i was like three or four and
everything they say like
matthew maddie maddie cameron
wayne naliafa and um grayson
and grayson grayson was 20s he didn't
play nineteen's he just came out of
nowhere there
yeah yeah but i just remember i was the
worst at that and then
i was like holy and then when i went
back to the turbos i really i talked to
the trainers when i missed out it was
pretty guttering i talked to
trainers like i need to wake up here
like what do i need to do and that's
where it sort of started
um like i had a really good club season
after that
and started getting i was doing boxing
in the morning to get fitter
um really started focusing on my weights
and then i got injured mate i got an um
hernia i i tried to score a try trying
to be bloody
the man in ruricha and i popped up
hernia so that really
put me back at the end of seven
but um rin's was the turbos coach and he
said look
get get right get fit and uh i'll give
you an honest crack at twenties
because the coaches weren't even looking
at me they just pretty much handed them
the book of the nine inch team so
that was my goal then so i just fell in
love with the um
turbofish trainer and um just tried to
make 20s really
which was the goal and then how did you
do that what what sort of
how did you start to love tackling how
did you get so fit what
what was the what was the secret any
secrets
teach me how to test no real secrets
yeah the tackling was more of a
um mentality thing i think like i
started playing club rugby playing with
me and started um
i remember i live with my mate mitchell
crozwell he's a good nike man
and uh yeah he's just like bro just
i don't know if i'm always going to make
a tackle but if i'm just going hard and
see what happens you know
so i started that trying that and you
know off the left-hand side scrum
you're like you mark first hands you
know so i won three cuts and then club
players and that aren't
like that deadliest so i was like
getting my head on the spokes and
make the odd tackle and then you know
all the strength
i was i got up to maybe 78 kgs sort of
08
yeah and then um yeah i think i put a
bit of weight on when i was injured so
then i got fit and then uh yeah but i
was doing a lot of extra running stairs
and back then the big one was like hill
repeat
so i did a lot of that and um
i was just really lucky i got i wouldn't
say i was any stronger than that but
i really started enjoying tackling which
really made me
when i when i got a tackle in early i
found out in a game my
running game would come alive because
i'd had a hit yeah
so for me i always try to look for a
tackle earlier i'll like fill in the
line get a tackle and then i'm like
you hope you get a little bit of a ding
because you sort of get it in a tackle
where you know you're not going to
really win the momentum but
yeah it's just a key part of my game and
i know when i don't do it i go missing
for a little while
but and then just yeah get him i had a
really good
20s trial though i'll be honest so
um yeah i i i i had a real good
relationship with um
trent and he played ten that day and for
me my team and
uh we had a real big pack and um
yeah i just i had a good try and um
maddie cameron didn't and i didn't
because he was all that luck with the
ranking system he was better
physically in that but i don't know if
it was renz who saw something or
gave me a bit more of a shot but no one
was beating grayson at the time he was
stronger than everyone yeah and look
like superman
and we used to call him i used to call
him superman he had a body of like
achilles i was like who the hell is this
guy
and you remember then he was the only
guy in our squad
besides that who played super he played
super ugly that year yeah
and played for auckland like it was like
wow this guy and he
he cleaned like 130 at um 20s camp i
still haven't seen anyone do that
honestly he's freakishly oh he and i
just want his body man
he had abs and muscles everywhere i was
like holy hell
but yeah we had a good ding dong battle
at 20s around who started and
yeah um yeah it was ren's playing us off
which was a bit of a bugger and saw me
more as an impact role
so it was fun and it was the first nzt
my maid mate so i was so happy and
you know the guys like k-pokey and all
that were pretty cool so
um yeah it was good to win yeah
how good and then coming back you
obviously got into the man with two
squad
was that the same year yeah yeah i made
two bows
yeah 2008 and then seven games in
uh lots of rock and bullet i could go to
they kicked it out auckland kicked it
out eden park yeah and i just got on and
i
pointed lots of like don't throw it in
he throws it straight at me
i catch it daniel braid tackles me
jackals me
and then i break my leg in the in the
rough oh wow
so it was a horrific yeah i broke my uh
footballer dislocated my ankle ripped my
hole
so it was uh yeah so i'm saying to
lottie
leave it leave it i've just shanked this
out on the 22. we're on the halfway i'm
like leave it
he throws it straight at me
and then when i was injured he came up
to me he's like if you gave it back i
would have scored i was like
if you didn't pass it i wouldn't have a
broken foot right now
so you know that was so then a weight
was done too
so yeah i was doing another another
offseason two in a row
of uh season ending injuries and it was
just a real bummer like
yeah like oh wait you know got my
turbo's contract finally
made the team i was getting 20 minutes
there
and me and cruden was sort of starting
to
me cruden and kurt and andre were like
young academy boys to come into
manoa 2 we were thriving and that was
the year well my injury was nothing like
prudence he got cancer
that same week you know so we had eight
injuries from that
it was a ram philly shield game in
auckland we ended up losing eight guys
that day
for the year it was like bread knockout
captain did his achilles
i broke my leg crude and got cancer it
was just
bad like a hamstring johnny did his
shoulder
it was just like yeah the cam was ruined
and
yeah but that was it so yeah and then uh
sort of 2009 the team was a struggle
mate i just couldn't
crack a super how was it mentally for
you to go through those um
injury setbacks we all good oh
man it was um it was tough because
um just wanted to i was like doing like
this three wins programs with the
hurricanes and that so i'd go down for
the old week
preseason and then a week in season so
that was really cool
getting in those environments meeting
all those legends
you know um but the injuries really made
me doubt um
what if this was for me because
sort of being smaller i just doubted
like if i could physically handle it and
um i remember thinking like i might
chuck it in
and just i was nearly doing qualified my
hairdressing and
i was kind of i had a two-year deal with
turbo so i was like do i
give up my rehab wasn't going very well
my ankle
well i wanted it to go quicker but it
just the ligaments are that damaged i
had to take
my time so um but
it came alright i just had to i quit
hairdressing to just focus on
my rehab yeah and when i did that it was
really it's probably the best thing
you know what it's like that assistant
trainer becomes your best mate when
you're injured
so our trainer at the time we just were
doing everything we could to just
just break it up but um
there were big doubts around i was just
i wasn't enjoying rugby because i
couldn't survive a season at that time
you know so
it was pretty tough but yeah the next
two years were really tough for me in
the sense of
i thought i was the man and i wasn't
i wasn't fit enough and strong enough
and
you know i thought nine and ten that i
just like oh yeah my potential will get
me picked for super rugby and
that'd be it but it didn't happen hey so
2009 i like played it right for the
turbos but
i was still a bit chubby from my injury
still
scared to get tackled at this time yeah
and uh yeah but i think 2010 summer is
when i really
just sort of i'll give it one more crack
um it was a rough year for the turbos we
nearly got
booted from the comp tasman were the
same women there yeah we were in there
yeah yeah it was a pretty tough time for
new zealand rugby and
um yeah it was it was just interesting
like
i needed the contract because i'd quit
hairdressing and yeah
um i signed a deal even though we hadn't
confirmed that we'd be there next year
so i was trying to play
second level yeah or whatever to get
that money but
it's true yeah it just 2010 was a very
lucky year for me had an all right my
out of ten but
jamie joe picked me full of maoris yeah
and only because pitty whippy made the
all blacks
so we were only two or three moldy
halfbacks and i was just lucky to sneak
him and
that was uh i'll be honest with you
chris smiley breaking his cheekbone was
the luckiest thing that could ever
happen to me to be honest because i got
to start in the
bar bars game or get i played 70 minutes
in the barbarians game
yeah and then i started the next two
games against uh
england a and ireland a and um
like i really that was that was my that
was my chance and i knew it was my last
chance
yeah and
um yeah that was that was sort of it and
i just
tried my best and jamie j you know
fulfilled my dream my dream was never to
make the oil breaks my dream was just to
play super ugly and at the time i was
like battling for
wider squad contracts or the next guy
and he rang me
round two of mitre 10
uh and said you know i'm going to full
contract you for the highlanders
and i was like i'm here man and jamie
joe's contract talks don't go very long
it was like i've got i'll give you two
days to make a decision
but you're one of the first guys i've
called
so yeah hope to hear from you soon later
bang hangs up
i rang warren i was like what do we do
here and he's like yeah
and he goes because i was at the blues
for the season
in 2010. yeah um me and az dixon and dan
pryor were the
with the broom cupboard boys i remember
so we were just in this broom cupboard
next to the changing room
but um yeah it was crack up man but
you know i didn't play a game at all
albeit madison made the all blacks that
yeah he played
every minute pretty much and he was on
fire man he was outstanding then so
um it was cool to watch to learn but
yeah same thing
losing one off for a contract and then i
rang the blues because
um i wanted to go back there because
i've been there in a season
and they said oh we're going to wait
till the end of the season see how you
go
i said sweet jam and joe's offered me my
dream i'm signing this
yeah and go on
then i'm off the donors how good and how
is that how is it going down there
um i think you're living with kurt baker
and jared hawata which with a couple of
absolute roosters so
it's your first taste to super rugby
oh mate it was pretty it was pretty
awesome mate because uh
you know we just you just uh that's when
you know you're playing rugby all year
round so it felt like i was like a pro
you know so yeah
play turbos have a month off then you
start yeah highlanders pre-season
stuff and then you know moved down to
donors
did the pre-season i just it was so cool
like yeah i'm getting paid
all year round to play rugby and i felt
like a pro and
it was cool and going to donors was
awesome it was um
yeah the 2011 was an awesome year um we
lived with hawada and like as you said
in kurt baker and his partner at the
time and
we had an awesome we had this pimp pad
we had like a
um rooftop kind of um flat
so because we got reallocation money
they just sorted it and they said
living we had this rooftop place had an
elevator like it was mean
glass everywhere we had our own rooms it
was like oh man
and it was the party house and we just
like lived it up
so um yeah but it was cool man
i met wendell our trainer and he just
like really challenged me to
you know get really fit and we had jimmy
count so
i had a really awesome time 2011. he was
going for
preparing for the world cup so he was in
the best shape and stuff so watching him
prepare for that was
cool and um you know just get 10 or 15
minutes here after games and
i got a couple of starts when he had his
all black rest so
uh it was pretty cool and but yeah i
think i uh
i enjoyed what dunedin has to offer off
the field too
into 2011 so we won four games in a row
and then
lost uh eight out of the next ten so
it was uh a bit of our squad got
challenged and then our
bond off the field grew bigger because
we were
yeah the highlanders obviously known for
their off-field social
antics how was it was it as much as as
you expected or
any stories from those days
oh i was it was um i don't know if it's
bad but it wasn't ideal looking back at
it now like
if we played a friday game and we had an
eight day turnaround we'd have a good
you know we had a good crew of us me
nasty
kaipuki hawada kirbaka guys like that
that enjoyed a good time
we were young so we were about 23 24 or
you know 21 to 24
except for hawada who was dirty probably
he's about 40 now so yeah um
no i love your hoe and then uh yeah we
just
so and nasty money on there and if we
yeah if we had a friday saturday we were
on
we were going good we'd have a good
night you know and then go again
saturday night and then just sweat it
all out
but that was it was sort of like that
then like as long as you're fronted
and you know i learned after that yeah
you can't
uh you know like the kindle at both ends
you know because
physically i was broken more from the
alcohol at the end of the year than i
was uh
the games you know i was only playing 20
minutes a week 15 max
and uh so yes so i i kind of used that
first year as my sort of
you know dunedin year and then 2000
2011 and i remember um having a bear
with jamie at the end of
the day any uh another moment in my life
where it was a light bulb moment
was uh you know i think uh because
maggie i think your
game is pretty good but uh
you love the piss too much mate and i go
oh yeah cool we're having a beer right
now all good
um but if you turn up next year
fit and ready to go um i'll pick the
best halfback for this team
i don't care if jimmy's want to work up
or not i'm going to pick the best
um the best halfback who i think sounds
like sweet
um and yeah so that whole summer
watched the world cup um loved that and
then
because it was a bigger bigger break
then we had a bigger preseason
yeah it was like eight weeks before
christmas then
before after and then all blacks came
back and you know i just went that was
the that was that was the year
i really went from like running uh
aiding one on the
yoyo to mid 19's
squatting and benching what i could and
then finally getting my skinnies kind of
down and
figuring out that if you have your skin
is right
um you're able to run longer train
better
and i was able to just play the way i
wanted to play for longer
not little patches and birds i could
just go until i got subbed really so
that was sort of where i learned that so
jamie joe lyder i
carved up preseason and he started
jeremy game one i was like you bastard
he lied but uh you know
i actually yeah we played the chiefs
round one and he started him
jimmy you know it was all good but i i
felt like i was
i'd started all the preseasons i played
well
i felt i knew the game plan and i was
you know and then
yeah i got on really early in the cheeks
game and i got to try
pretty quickly and i started every game
after that that year
you've cracked it you've done it well
to be honest that was um just trying to
speak jimmy everywhere
in 2012 yeah because that was the goal
so um yeah i kind of it was a bit of a
whirlwind year
um i wouldn't say i played any better or
anything but
i was playing a different brand of
halfback to others at the time
yeah um i was just playing fast clearing
the ball
trying to get second touches um
sniping around the rock a bit yeah and
yeah as i said that would sort of win
the um
speed of speed of play and the way we
were playing at the hollanders
you know showcased my game and we had to
play quick
and and and a very blessing in disguise
was that was the first year we played on
four side bar so it just
suited me to a t and um
you know what we were able to start
creating from 2012 to sort of
leading up to 21st thing was sort of all
built on the stadium
the culture and then guys like ben smith
and nasimanu
um but yeah it was it was awesome
but yeah like uh
i got i remember getting named in the uh
all blacks camp
and it was a shocking so i was on one of
the uh
saturday sunday drinking sessions as we
did in the landers
yeah and i got a text to like eight at
nine
or seven at night on a saturday and i'm
uh
yeah thinking uh cool it's gonna be a
cool night and then bulmets like
hi darren shand here all black manager
um
on monday you will be coming into a
training camp
so i'm sitting there going oh my god i
need to go to the german
streets and the stuff out you know oh
shoot
so uh yeah it was uh and i'm sitting
there on the couch with all the boys we
were having a good time and they're like
what's happened i'm like
just sitting there just like oh my god i
just showed them my phone and it's like
a message from those like 502 one
numbers you know just like
yeah it's a group text and oh man i was
just like
far i'm going in the camp and then yeah
like the next two mondays i went into
camp and um
you know it was it was crazy what was it
like
who was good to you and what what was it
what was the feeling going in
oh man i um we went into camp in north
shore
they're like camps two days we'd just go
through attack structures and stuff and
i had conrad smith as my um
as my roomie so it was quite nice to get
a nice leader in there but
um yeah it was a it was a crack up
because um
i remember sleeping on the monday night
and his room
was where the bathroom was yeah so i was
like i needed a
toilet but i i didn't know um
i didn't want to wake him up you know i
wasn't going to go bursting into his
room to get to the bathroom
so i'm like i remember um
yeah i heard i waited like two hours i
heard him go to the bathroom and then i
got up straight after
oh he's sneaky so sweet and then i like
winning
i'm sitting there just like freaking out
and they're like i need to go to the
bathroom and i'm just sitting there
lying there like
trying to think of anything but gun
toilet and then i
finally he went and i just got up went
to the bathroom and
yeah but that was the first camp and
that was
cool and you know to meet legends of our
game
makua but in wellington
i had carter as my roomie and i couldn't
believe how much the guy could
slip like i don't know if he had a big
weekend before
but any time between our training
sessions he was just napping
and i was just crack yeah and then um
i thought the camps because the camps
there were five or six players there in
each position so you don't know but
i remember um carter was talking to me
just before we left on the monday night
and he's like oh i'll see you next week
and i go hey and he goes oh yeah
catch you later kid and then i was like
what do you mean by that and then i
thought you know i was like oh no
we were talking about attack stuff and
plans and that and he was like oh yeah
when you hit me on this we'll do that
and then this now oh yeah and he goes
sweetheart and he goes oh well make sure
you remember that stuff and i'll see you
next week and i was like holy
does that mean i'm in the all blacks or
what on that and then
the worst thing was we were playing the
crusaders a week so i was probably like
that's what he meant he's just going to
be like oh yeah
yeah so uh yeah and then
the next sunday the best day of my life
happened you know
how did it come about
um yeah we were just um
we had andrew hoare jose gear
and adam thompson and the team in the
highlanders as well at the time
yeah and um yeah we were um
we were at our hotel and we were just
just before about to leave to go to the
airport and
i saw andrew hall leave the room ricky
and then i saw jose leave
and i was like oh [ __ ] and then
[Music]
and then my phone rang and then i was
like oh my god here we go
because they said they'd ring you no
matter what like yeah yeah you know
and jose and it came back pretty coy in
there and i was like damn what does that
mean and then
darren chandy just cut straight to the
chase hello aaron
um uh i'll get i'll be quick
and i was like oh here we go and i am
like my heart's beating i'm shaking
going
yeah i'm gonna cry if you'd say no here
and then he's like uh
you've made the team um you'll fly up
tonight
um see tonight congratulations and i was
like oh my god and
i just remember just shaking like makes
me a bit
thing now but yeah just like oh my god a
punk kid from fielding can cricket you
know i've done it and uh
yeah it was um yeah it was surreal bro
just
the best part was bringing my parents
next i rang i rang my um
mom and dad they obviously i told them
what was happening they said they'd ring
me no matter what this morning
and i'll ring you and i know and i um
rang my mom and i kind of thought it'd
be funny to play a bit of a prank i was
like oh you know
nah i didn't make it mum and it's okay
and she's like oh
i love you it doesn't matter you'll be
there next year and i go nah nah i made
it mama and then
she was happy and then when i rang my
dad it was a bit weird like i rang my
bed it was a dumb prank stupid thing
yum what an ego really special moment
and i
pranked my mom what a what an idiot i
always i haven't said sorry for that but
oh
god dumb joke and then i rang my old man
and just sit down here and
uh he went pretty quiet and ah
yeah but man it was just it was awesome
and
um all that work and uh
yeah it paid off and then the debut how
was how did that come about
yeah so that was that was pretty cool
just um
you know they named the team on the
tuesday in the changing room before you
train
so i'm sitting there pity weepies in
camp and there's only me and him so i'm
thinking sweet
i might i'm on the bench no matter what
here sweet ass
so i'm day burn this weekend i mean
um oh they named the team on tuesday
morning so put your boots on jerseys on
gps sit down and wait and it was pretty
serious everyone's sitting there and i
was like okay this is how they do it in
all blacks
and then boom karen reed number eight
number nine aaron smith and i was like
oh no oh no because impacting the game
and starting way different a you know
like yeah
impact you just sort of come on
whatever's the flow of the game and like
you know
rip in but start and you've got to like
build the game get it going
oh man and then but pity was great he
helped me all week
and it was just a it was an amazing ride
amazing week and uh
i just remember gang day being so scared
to um
get injured or do something too much
like
it sounds ruthless but andrew all week
was saying all these things like you're
not an all black team player game
and uh okay yeah and then like he's like
you don't want to be one of those guys
that
who's a one tips or two tests and i was
like okay man i get it like
yeah don't be there go ahead and then
like game day and then the warmer i was
like i'd
like jogging around and then then even
in the hakka i didn't go hard because
i don't want to pull a car for something
silly
so like i was not i wasn't like i wasn't
excited about the anthem or the haka
because i was just so scared about
getting hurt like
i remember in the warm up and then as
soon as the kickoff happened
i was like it's done i'm an all black
now and then i remember
running up the field from dan kicking
the ball going
i need a warm up
i'm not even like oh oh and i remember
like
thinking like oh god but um no it was
yeah the first test was a bit of a the
second and the third was great but
yeah it was just really weird like other
stories people had but mine was that
like i was so
scared of like getting hurt before the
game
i i just trod it around man like all
blacks warm-ups are chill
you do you do everything and then 10
minutes to go you come in and do passing
waves
tackles going so it's like it's all up
to you
yeah it's all self-driven so i just
trotted around like
you can't get hurt avoiding contact or
anyone oh
that's closer and then yeah
no that was that was i just feel bad
telling people oh you know putting the
jersey on nah man i was so scared to
get hurt i didn't do anything to get
hurt
oh it's so good and then back to your
landers career obviously
150 games that's a massive
massive achievement you've been there
for ages
playing real good footy what any
highlights of your career that you're
keen to share other than the 215 final
great great game um no it does the
lenders are
special to me obviously they gave me a
shot and i love
i love the way we play we play on a
stadium yeah it
promotes a positive brand of rugby so um
you know at least i know half my games
are rugby are going to be with a dry
ball so
that's pretty exciting to know every
year um
and you're always going to get people's
bests at our stadium because everyone
gets excited about playing there
i don't know what it's like for you
coming down to play but you know it's
going to be awesome game
and then um yeah just just lucky
they i couldn't have made all blacks
without the hollanders and
i've always tried to pride myself on
being an all black that um
tries to play well at super i didn't
want to be one of those all blacks that
just
used super ugly to build for all blacks
yeah i've always tried to
come and fit lead lead through example
and
and always try to get better and um in
the last few years
it's been great just i had ben smith to
follow for years they say
i was just as trying to compete with him
every day he was my other guy you know
so
yeah my whole my most well this was my
first year without him but
other than that i was just following his
lead and he's such a great leader
and a great man so um he led the way
through
standards and actions and that and let
his talking
happen on the field you know wasn't a
big talker but he grew into an amazing
captain and i just followed him and the
last couple of years obviously just been
able to
build that leadership role with ash but
um
yeah super rugby is where you make your
money will make your goal day because
that's where like you don't all blacks
you
you're behind the rolls royce so yeah
you're behind a great team you know but
i reckon that super you get a better
feeling because
you earn everything you get you know and
at the highlanders we do you know so
anything we get every time we make the
playoffs
like um you know probably
like we've made the playoffs every year
since 2014 like
one of the years we snuck in but yeah
like as a team
of misfits from all over we we battle
high above our expectations you know and
i think the times where we've had great
teams we've gone far
and sometimes and then 2015
we got a little bit of luck but we had
uh
we had three or four guys that had the
best seasons of their life
and um and we got on a roll
when it counted and that was uh
you know and as as i've played you know
as i played so much super ugly it's so
hard to win
so it is you know too how hard it is and
when you won your one i'm
sure it was the same feeling of just
like relief and
uh amazingness but like to get even in a
final
you have to be at home or in new zealand
you know
it's so such a hard thing to win that
yeah
well how did you guys do it how did you
do it away from home
well we were lucky there i mean in new
zealand like we've
the two times we made the semis were
both skimmies were a
job you know yeah so it's just so hard
and even if you won that game you're
coming home to a new zealand final like
yeah it's impossible to do you know but
2015 we were lucky that
the tars were carving up so
we we'd finished second behind the
hurricanes yeah who smoked us both times
we played them that year
jamie joe jamie and joe had a plan
though he's like we only have to beat
the hurricane
once and he rested me muller and bender
the second game and napier
yeah and he goes if we're gonna win this
comp because you guys have lost
one game and however many he's like
we're gonna beat them in a final if
if we if we make it and i was sitting in
a leadership meeting like i want to play
tj
what are you on about i'm an ap is my
hometown like i'm from the bay
my multi-siders all my family there yeah
he's like stay home
train hard and get ready because we're
going to africa and then
um it was a great plan from him and
suicide for us
but it's what our team needed and um
yeah and then we just you know we played
the chiefs at home
in a quarter which is probably still one
of the most memorable games for me
um when we had a great night waisaki
ripped up and
we won at home a quarter at home and
then we went to sydney
and i remember sitting on instagram on
the monday and i saw um um
what's that six's name for them um
uh the african dude he put up an
instagram post and i printed it out
uh i had a photo of him in the gym with
the boys and he goes
can't wait for the next two week uh
blues brothers
here we come finals and i was like oh so
they're already in the final boys
so i printed it out oh wow they had all
these other articles
like sydney herald and that like oh
waratahs
birth to make another final um
you know and i was just like and jamie
joe was the same as that we just built
it up
yeah and we just built this up and we we
smoked the cars
smoked them 38 10 i think yeah you know
we just
absolutely game plan was outstanding and
then
it was all about yeah coming home to
have a crack at a hurricane really that
was our way and our plan and we had a
good plan that night to try and beat
yous and uh
and and we uh we we got lucky
so you took those and you um and you run
there was some game
and the intensity of it was just next
level obviously i never played him
if you watch the first go watch the
first 30 minutes you probably don't want
it but it's like
it's a free-for-all and no one wants to
kick a penalty out or kick it we just
quick tap
everything both teams quick throws
you guys never took a line out you just
threw everything in and then
um scutter and the bus and yourself and
oh yeah it was just you know um
as i said you're just big moments and
you just
uh waisaki and lima and um
malala had had nights and then elliot
had a night you know like we just
and i'll take it man and i've i've
played a lot of highlanders rugby now
and and it's still
right up there best moment ever and it's
so hard to win super heavy so
big respect to anyone that can do it
yeah did he score it
yeah i said yeah
[Laughter]
i think slo-mo actually helped it
because that fast motion i thought he
dribbled up that yeah
helped that he didn't look convinced
when he got up so
yeah but obviously yeah the team i gave
it
to chris's history it's funny how
perception should i like i don't even
think of that because it's a try
but for you guys it's like that was the
moment but that's fair
i've you know i've been on the other end
of that stuff too no i
i'm like that the same i wouldn't even
notice that during the game it's more
after the game when you look back and
you
start dwelling on moments and you're
like oh was it a try or
could we have scored there and you start
counting all these things you're like
sure we were robbed but in reality yeah
you come off that field and you know
that you haven't won that game and
you've been beaten by yeah we had a good
day that day
sorry mate you won it the next year it's
all good yeah that's all good one each
we'll
we'll take it and then let's go back to
your all blacks
97 caps
that's massive 95 points you're on a
race to a hundred
hey oh i kept the conversion somewhere
did you
must be on like i have yeah
is it 97 points 95 caps well whatever it
is it's an odd
way you know it's there's a 2 somewhere
um
bodhi twisted his ankle light in a
bledisloe and
he's like i can't kick this and tj was
on the wing at the time
and me bender and and tj were around
um stephen lewis who had the kicking
tees yeah
red the t get out of here boys
so like um one of the boys put someone
straight under the post
and he was like right 79th minute so
i put the tea down and i like i could
grab the tea and bender and tj like
i just walk off and i grab the ball and
i set it up
but i set it up like sort of oliver meet
his back not far yeah the game's over
we're beating in aussie second test by
like 20.
and then drew mitchell and eddie master
coop are going to try to charge me
and i've gone quite far back and i'm
gone oh
and i'm like they're gonna charge me
down and i just like quickly come and
bang like yeah
got it and i'm so happy but yeah because
my goal kicking record at super
aggregates oh and three and
one of them that was one of lima's
questions actually what's your
goal at the landis
he won't let it go i wouldn't have to
kick it if he didn't get simmered
yeah i'm trying to shoulder charge lady
nice nice lena
where was your kick from where were your
kicks from nah
they were one was uh another tony brown
our coach now was trying to jack a
little rock
and invercargill got penalized third in
a row
yeah so i we scored a try against the
brumbies 15
left side just scraped the right upright
and then um same one we scored five
minutes later we actually went better
without him on the field which was funny
and then it was on the other other other
15
that went left this time just and then
there was the famous one in
dunedin and christchurch where i try to
use the whole two minutes or long as
yeah and then i could actually see
myself on the screen behind the thing
and it doesn't go any higher than the
crossbar like it's
a shocker okay you know i can
i can hit a goal kick now i know how to
mentally goal kick like i can just get
up there
trust my kick bang it yeah where's back
then it was like a whole lot but now i
could actually i could hit one ear the
sticks and i'll go it'll go near the
sticks you know
but i'm older now i've kicked a lot so
i'm like okay but
back then it was like oh i need to take
up the whole time i'm taking my time and
then
i don't even think it makes like goes
yeah it nearly hits crocky or someone in
the head and then it's like a worm
burner
and they pick it up and start countering
it doesn't even make the like big bore
or anything
that's bad man i love that stuff
oh but anyway you've had a really
successful all blacks career so
um what games stand out for you
obviously you're a world cup winner that
must be pretty special
right right up there yeah this is um
i think there's random games that stand
out like um
2013 we had like the gamer games and
johannesburg
and ellis booth uh ellis park and uh
that was like one of the hardest games
i've ever played um
2013 beating ireland on the hooter like
yeah that last passage of play
like it's still something i'll never
remember like finding the energy
in the 80th minute it was just like the
end of the year
i like watch me i've watched that clip a
lot and
when i feel tired and then i go watch it
but um
then um
what else is there but yeah the whole
world cup 2015 was
outstanding um but looking back on it
just like the legends i got to play with
they like
you don't know it at the time as a young
fellow you're just riding the wave and
when i look back i looked at the team
photo a little while ago when i was
working out
um going through my um photos on it and
like
the guys in that photo are like legends
and they say
are grateful for that and then obviously
missing out on the world cup last year
and not winning and or failing
kind of makes you appreciate like 2015
and winning because
it does come down to like pressure
moments and like
say the semi last year and the semi and
africa when we played them like we
nailed our moments in the african one
and we did an
england one you know so yeah it's just
it's sad man it's hard because
yeah but hey um yeah just
i'm very lucky i've won a lot of games
with all blacks played some awesome
players
you know games for me too like i said
around uh wanting people to do well like
bodhi and 2018
against australia like seeing that it's
still up there for me
um you know like him scoring all those
points all those tries
like that stuff's cool um
i don't know like the quarter final i
mean the bronze medal game
me and bender did like a trick move
around the blind and it was like
i still think it's the best paths i've
ever thrown in a game
like i throw this blind pass which steve
hanson came up with he's like
we're going to do this trick move around
the back of the line out and then just
throw it
to the space and the winger will um
bender will find it or whatever wing it
is yeah i was like okay
and i've literally just like thrown it
hoping and bender's just like hit it
like a bat out of hell
and then fans two dudes and scores and
i'm just like goes
ballistic but yeah it's weird but
um yeah i'm really grateful for my time
in all black jersey
it's a amazing team to be a part of
luck i've been lucky injury-wise too
i've touched wood now
um and just that's just what uh
it's why you play and that's why i play
now and um
being a father and um that it just
making those memories of luca like i had
lucra eden park
for the um test stay there i think one
of the better games i've ever played
um the quarter against ireland um
luca was in the stands and like i just
got real emotional about it and
um it was silly because all the i went
up to see luca and tegan and
all the japanese like mauled us all like
came over and
kind of freaked figgy out and luca was
small and i was
quite worried so we didn't bring it to
another game but
he was there for that one and i was
that'll be a moment and i'll never
forget
and i was able to chuck the lucha up for
my boy so
you're gonna try so i was happy yeah so
that'll be things i'll cherish but
yeah i hope it's not done for me i i
feel like i've got a lot to offer and
i want to kind of um see how long i can
go and
um you know the the jersey demands
you to be the best you could be and
that's just sort of how i
sort of approach every day now yeah and
you've obviously kept your um
you've obviously been the regular nine
in the in the all blacks starting jersey
um with a lot of competition from one of
the most competitive guys
i've ever played with tj so talk to me
about
your relationship with him and um how
that sort of goes
yeah tj is a um oh man he's uh
you say competitive he's feisty
character yeah but um
we get on really well we obviously got a
really good working relationship
and uh um competitive one
but um i can't compete with him in a lot
of things as you know
he's strong as if not the fittest dude
on the field he's one of them
and he just he's good at everything mate
yeah you know
any sport anything basketball would play
the bird
golf whatever i'm pretty sure he could
be good at and
um you know we get on really well off
the field we're
both now and stuff like that and we've
grown up together really
yeah but um yeah i'm being very lucky i
guess
there were some points there my old
black career where people probably
thought
tj was better or playing better and
steve
maybe chose me and used him as that
impact role but
um yeah man for man we both have always
just respected who
we always saw it as one two punch that's
what we say to each other
whoever gets the job the guy comes on
and finishes it you know with the
the second punch so that's how we see it
it's the unit
you know test rugby you never see a guy
i play 80 anymore it's always
60th minute speed the game i bring a guy
on and
i think i've just been lucky enough to
um get the nod in a lot but
i'll be honest with you um i wouldn't be
here without tj
because you know in the off season
i just think tj be training right now
yeah um that's weird man like
i only see his face but it gets me out
of bed
you know yeah any um battles between you
and him that stand out
at super level
or it would be i remember
oh i'll be honest probably not anything
that's like outrageous i remember in
um we played each other 2012 and dunners
and um he like
stepped around the rack fended a guy
had me to go i went to ball and all of
them like god i'm good
and then he just goes get off me spun
slam the ball down
try got out done his normal thing
and i've gone jesus
you know i was feeling pretty good and
like oh yeah i saw him offend the guy
i'm just going to go
bonfire here yeah he just got rid of me
like nothing and
um yeah but nothing half breaks never
get too many run-ins with each other but
yeah i remember making a couple of
tackles on him in that final light
he was trying to get a second touch and
i was just mirroring him like you're not
going to score
you're not going to score anyway but
someone else maybe but
yeah i remember tackling him once but
yeah
this year he got me good he's he dummied
me
like rock defender and that's
the game right there and i scored later
on and yeah yeah it was all good one
more
but um yeah it cracks me up the older
yeah we're just halfbacks man we just go
hard and yeah um
like with all of them in in my career
and all the blacks around
you know pity he was competitive uh tkb
that was probably the most competitive
group we had me
him and tkb was like out the gate
like all in our own ways like that was
all all energy
tj's all energy vigor and tkb could just
hit
yeah outstanding 40 player but if you
get training
like hit hit yeah like you do a drawing
pass you're getting hit
like fight your like the same the same
two hand touch he
hits so always love those battles with
both of them and uh
oh my middle part of my well during
those
sort of 2012 to sort of 15 16 like
every week playing either andy alice uh
tkb
and or tj it was like awesome
yeah you know so it was like awesome
competitiveness and uh
yeah but yeah your body's feeling pretty
good
now have you got have you got much
planned for the for the rest of your
future yeah just sort of
i'm trying to talk for uh maybe hanging
around till the
next world cup so we'll see what happens
there offensive are you are keen
i've still got another year on my
contract so um
i feel i feel in great shape great
mind and uh obviously um
i'm getting married in january and we've
got a little boy so
hopefully try to have another another
baby soon
so um i preferably like to stay around
and
um you know i love playing in new
zealand and
the all black jersey still drives me
every day and that to
try and play there and so i'm playing
highlanders is i'm a passionate about
that and
uh a co-captain at that club so i love
love that so you know who knows but um
yeah like you said about goals in it
like
um now i'm preparing for super rugby in
my mind and i so i'm starting to get
ready for what's coming uh
bender's on 150 ball game
so that's my next target 155
so that's uh that's how it worked mate
so yeah
now i'm trying to get ready for super so
it's on to the next sort of uh
campaign as you know it's a bit of a
slog but
it keeps you fresh it keeps you
energized and uh i think when i
run out of things to do or
things i feel like i can't achieve i
think i'll walk away happy
but if my body lets me i will chase
everything i can get out of this amazing
game and
it's given me a lot so uh by no means
it's
done but um yeah i'm inspired all the
time you know like
guys like dang coles in there still
doing it um
yeah like i sit around you seeing the
guys how much work they put in the sam
why looks
the guys like that it doesn't just
happen ace so there's a reason why
they've played that many games
over that many years and and as an older
athlete
you you follow guys like lebron the
ronaldo's the mercies
yeah and you see what they do and
you know as you get older the game does
get easier to play because
you've been in so many situations so
yeah some people may
think this is a really hard situation
and there but i've been in a lot
so you can oh yeah we're only down by 10
or you know whatever the situation or
i've been
taken out off the ball worse than that
or that was cheaper than that but
you know that's what that's what's
exciting
and then just trying to get young guys
to enjoy
trying to help them achieve their goals
you know that's what i want i want
as many highlanders to make the all
blacks as possible you know yeah
turbos to make super rugby's like that's
why i play as well and
um you know i think i owe that to the
hollanders
they gave me my shot and you're happy
with the highlanders
squad that you've got for the 2021
season
i'll tell you i'm happy we've got the
raging bull back liam squire
that gets me going so happy to see him
back
it's been a lot of messages between us
all talking
and this and there and uh yeah it's uh
it's cool our squad's great tony brown's
our coach and i love playing under him
something about him ignites my game um
he just he just challenges me constantly
about trying to get better and i love
that and uh
it's always under me around my game and
what am i seeing what am i feeling
what am i uh executing better and
you know ash dixon i think said the best
year he's been outstanding this year so
yeah uh i go on the record today and i
think he's been the best player
in the country so hopefully he gets the
kudos for that this year
and uh i really hope he gets um the
accolades he deserves he's been
outstanding minor 10 and super
yeah i love the old man cuddle of smudgy
um so much love boy and uh
yeah we've got a great young squad um
yeah charles back challenges back
[Music]
oh god he's going to be intense with d
in this so that'll
be good he'll bring some energy in that
area i know his uh
ruthless feedback i wonder if he's got
any softer
but uh you're gonna be sure
he's gonna be trying to get me to be t1
all the time tackling under the wall
yeah but yeah we've got some good
exciting boys mate can't wait
and uh you know what super ugly's like
it's just
um you know who's going to have that
kind of year can you have a young guy as
a breakout year or
is he someone who's just going to just
rip up so
um yeah well what a
what a journey and what good exciting
times ahead
well as always i've gone to the
instagram for some questions
and she's when i get legends on like you
mate they come flying in all sorts some
won't be asked but
um we've got a few good ones
um who's the best nine you've played
against this was asked 10 times so this
was like a real popular question
everyone wants to know
it's the guy easy for me the guy i've
idolized when i grew up was fruity free
from south africa yeah he is he is the
man and i he i watched clips clip 7
before
games still i have like uh i have
youtube premiere and i have
downloaded the highlights video oh
that's he's out the gate mate and um
yeah i was very lucky to beat him a few
times but
i was i was yeah standing in awe every
time i played him and i've got his
jersey
i swapped the couple with him and uh
yeah he's that guy for me
nice um toughest player to tackle
ah
dwayne benmeulen oh hi yeah
i've had i've had some horror stories of
them yeah
there's a video of me getting fly squad
same same tech that got tried with tj
the old ball and all i don't know why i
do it
i'm going to get this guy i just get the
big
the
yeah yeah it is what it is but um hey
that's rugby it's rugby
uh best advice for a young nine this one
came through a lot too
past past pass um past past pass here
keep passing every day and um
yeah build a good combo with it nice
solid
um is it how did you get your pass so
good
uh practice and uh
just trying to i use my thumbs a lot i
pass
and these two fingers really so when i
pass the ball
yeah so i i try to create talk with my
wrists
so that's my strength i think sure
favorite basketball from your card
collection
oh i got a few goodies um i've got a
lebron james um ps10
rookie card coming from it'll be at home
when i get home so that's the pretty big
card
and i've got a um spectra rpa
of jason tatum one of 25. i'll go
get it actually yeah there it is
haha say auto signature
and yeah it's pretty fat so i got it in
australia so
i usually have to ask tj if it if the
cards are worth anything or not so
they are yeah how much time big investor
yeah
he said you're a big investor in uh his
company but i've tried to pull back
i've narrowed my vision so i'm uh you're
supposed to just pick a guy and chase
him
so during lockdown i just bought
everything i could get my hands on
which was bad so i've sold a lot of
cards to um
get my bank balance back to even which
has been good um
and now i just chase jason tatum i think
he's going to be the next guy
so that's who i'm chasing and uh
and lebron's so lebrons are so hard to
get and now he's just want to chip it
they've gone even more expensive so i
sold about
yeah a few grand worth of cards to buy
one that one lebron
hockey card so but that card will go up
so
you can't lose on lebron he's just too
good you know
sounds good sounds like a good
investment okay
uh thoughts on philao fakatava
unreal he's uh he's a wizard um
and he's coming so
uh i might have to change my vision to
fallout getting me up in the morning so
yeah athletically um his
game understanding is growing and his
ability to
to play ball off edward is out the gate
so
yeah i'm looking forward to watching the
maldives um
moana pacifica game so i'll be watching
him and uh
yeah he's uh he's a great player and
he's a great kid and
yeah it's good stuff and this leads on
to the other one
now that tj's gone to the canes would
you ever move up there
no they didn't want me in 2008 9 or 10
or 11. um
no yeah and uh i grew up a hurricane's
fan
no doubt yeah cali jonah
you know i love them loved it winter
big games there but hey we all find our
way
um no hate there just um i used to be
a bit like that but not anymore just um
when guys move teams
and stuff but if i can i would
definitely try and
be a one club man and i'm sure you will
um best coach you've had and why
tough um jamie joe
around his way he challenged me
to be the best and uh
the way you saw the game and the way he
approached it mentally
challenged me a lot around my
preparation
and he just had a big heart he knew how
to talk to me
and get the best out of me um somehow
so any time i see him we have like
two types of ketchups we have like a
chill catch up have a feed and stuff
yeah and then we have like a rugby one
and he's really brutally honest with me
around what he sees and anytime i really
and i think i know when i try to call
him is when i think i need a bit of a
reboot or a better honesty you know
yeah so he knows that so he just gives
it to me
and uh yeah and i just owe him a lot he
gave me my chances so
i think that feeling of him will always
be there
that's cool last question
how did you get your nickname nagi oh
um nickname maggie 2007 i played club
rugby at third and yellows and
um we had a fijian captain he was a big
fijian guy and he said uh i scored
a couple of tries in my day boo and we
won big and he goes i'm very lucky
we have the golden nugget aaron smith
and i had to come up and do a handle
oh sure you know you players of the day
yeah
yeah oh wasted we played a farming
farming team and this guy just ate the
jug
yeah i ate the handle yeah but yeah that
was that like
golden it was just golden nugget and
then it was nugget
and then just the typhoon down to nagi
so
you take a good nickname early i've been
blessed
there's some shockers out there
you've come up trump's there and you've
come up trump's in your career and it's
been awesome to hear
um your pathway from when you're young
and going through your journey
i i've loved watching your career
progress from that under 19's camp
seeing how you've done it go through all
the teams all the way to the top the
absolute pinnacle of the game
um 97 95 caps for the all blacks
150 for the highlanders it's just
massive
achievements and um really
really enjoyed watching your career and
um thanks for coming on the water
podcast
cheers awesome big fan thanks mate